[Music]
welcome back to another chapter of dirty
RT this is chapter 16 we're again there
before we get into it though there is
some spoiler warnings that we have to go
through first if you haven't finished
Red Dead Redemption or if you want to
know what happens don't watch this video
yeah get out of here and come back when
you're done another spoiler a little bit
of spoilers but a lot of people in the
comments have been asking for this and
we've been waiting for the right time to
do it and we think now is the time to
reveal dirty Johnny easier or exciting
but oh we're getting some rain here oh
damn so someone tweeted at us a dirty
arty timeline yeah and I think we've
just thrown a wrench in that whole thing
and yeah I feel bad for him because it
looks like he did a lot of work and now
we're throwing in a new one we're
throwing in a whole nother timeline it's
got its Kyle I feel like the Zelda
timeline z' work yeah you know you'd
like to think they all make sense but
when you start looking at him it's just
all over the place and that's fine you
know it leaves us plenty of options to
go back and forth to like once online
maybe gets a little better there's more
content and we can go back to dirty
already on the online Pigman and now we
have dirty Johnny one thing I'm really
excited for is we have a whole new
repertoire of insults we can throw yeah
at poor civilians yeah we have like all
these new dialogue options also a whole
new area I know more importantly we have
an entire new area to explore yeah and
that's we're gonna head right now
originally we were gonna go to Valentine
but we're like you know what
dirty Johnny's base of operation isn't
gonna be Valentine you know it's gonna
be for reals new Austin Blackwater Oh
black yeah Blackwater yeah yeah yeah
that's the one
that's the one yeah so what we gonna do
this episode man we have so much turf to
to go over I feel like but I think we
can oh damn - the Lightning was pretty
cool I think first you know we have we
have to put meat on the bone we got to
get the hair growing out I think we can
at least start with getting a new attire
some dirty Johnny attire yeah I think so
too
there she is Johnny's old stomping
grounds all right so first we'll go to
the store all right where should we
start
how about you straight up outfits good
get an understanding of what's popular
in Blackwater not really sold on any of
these had these are all fancy okay
tumbleweed that's the ghost town we want
to go to right right you know what else
we should do you gotta go to a show and
sand the knee and heckle
oh hell yeah god there's so much to do
general Staal hello come on
Oh something good oh damn that's pretty
good yeah that looks pretty bad I love
to see her and like real time like
getting you all these items the local
saloon yes go through it yeah go through
them all this guy does not care at all
knowing you you would explode this whole
bunch food in your gut and your belly oh
my god
oh no no well that's a good way to leave
your mark on Emily nice scream oh we
want to get rid of his best that's what
we want to do once they buy your own
[ __ ]
I deserve that tumbleweed sucks some
weed sucks well well looks like the
fireplace is going this guy's a fighter
mm-hmm just decked his wife okay see you
guys later
I'll be back I'm sure
thanks for the tobacco just leaving our
mark on new Austin I feel like I've
gotta come up with a new voice for dirty
Johnny - interesting
I love how like if you run into their
first reaction is just to shoot you I
think like it's got to be more of an
accent for John
maybe armadillo there's a plague over
here there's a new plague in town his
name's dirty Johnny yep oh it was
wearing that guy or attack this blood
head this is really cruel you know the
best way to get rid of plagues and stuff
I think I have an idea where this is
going
you're cured you're welcome you're cured
where do you think you're going you're
running this afire oh we're just helping
I'm saving this town
[Music]
I can't let the infection spread it's
true I can't let it spread
they were clearly leaving none I'm doing
the world the justice that's very fair
yes that's the cooler run oh yeah
perfect all right
this town is clean this is how they get
rid of the plague for Red Dead 1 John
actually comes here and burns everyone
alive totally and then and then in the
opening credits of Red Dead one you see
that guy there I do
[Music]
how many other lines you have oh my god
here this another few minutes like a
path bag of the millions of wines they
recorded I guess this guy just got stuck
with two I mean it works I mean they're
pretty solid lines I really work for a
whole lot well much do you like him I
read the lines work for everything
that's going on it's not good god no
he's not wrong oh and don't brag I wanna
hear a little crazy don't run away
oh good god no oh oh Jesus Christ oh
good god you couldn't pick two lines are
a little more different
idiot Eliana just gonna shut somebody
else little dog shut your mouth a new
friend that first shot is like oh god oh
[Music]
this is mine now nope nevermind just I
have to break all these horses where's
my horse you can't see me here he kind
of froze up after that first shot
oh you don't I don't like this town yeah
we'll pay off our bounty or no I guess
we don't need to pay off or gotta take a
train huh another Gavin guess it's a
Gavin guy
[Music]
Gavin's friend we're just here for
Gavin's friend okay so we want to go to
San Danny to see if we can get a cool
hat mm-hmm or we could go to Valentine
and get the raccoon and we could see if
that guy's around it could be a
guarantee if you haven't gone it yet oh
dang I missed that dang it that's how I
got rid of the body from there okay he
doesn't really look at him they still
hang horse thieves you know that weren't
so bad you lost your pride I said you're
a [ __ ]
you a man you sure ridiculous look at
you
come here one sec I think we're in the
clear
good nice new whip keep it I've got a
really small neck John's burns are so
slightly off just like not they're not
that bad okay
like Arthur's got some poetry to it away
he rip someone's soul apart a small neck
like [ __ ] so do we need to wait till
night for oh we might well you can you
can in the meantime go to the get a
hotel room yeah yeah it sounds like a
good idea we can also get some more hair
tonic mm-hmm oh yeah Johnny beautiful oh
yeah
God he is filthy
come on hey didn't react I know
oh yeah you got the room right or did
you oh my god no it's always pretty
jarring where we go gentlemen
these guys really don't care at all oh
sorry let me close it for you that's one
way to steal a cart shouldn't run those
people over blend in I know
oh I thought there was a river is so
okay let me take a nap yeah we need that
saloon here
[Music]
and now it's time for show us your arty
segue here we have Aiden Aiden grossy or
Grassi Aiden Grassi just you know
classic already right there yeah I got
the sheriff badge too and and got a unit
of a horse with them hell yeah
bunch of cans and got the nice hat too
mm-hmm very colorful just hanging out in
his camp with this big ol hat shine
yellow hat and those blue jeans laddered
with blood yeah oh this is artsy yeah
art Morgan here oh you got him I have we
had before I think art Morgan is
sentient some just notice the poo coming
out of the horse but sick sick pose oh
yeah there's also mid poop as well also
I miss how long people wait like they
just the horse's poop pretty frequently
but still I feel like they set that up
but they're like wait wait wait yeah I
like this one I like the beard flares
out it's it's weird-looking kinda lit
look kind of looks like like a small
head I don't know
but nice can of beans down there has can
right there
oh we got a nice collage collage that's
a very long trench coat there that is I
dig it that's from bihari William sorry
for mispronouncing that name this one's
a little dark it looks like it's in a
van horn or yeah I think that's van horn
doc I think maybe yeah I don't know but
I do like the backdrop yeah it looks
like he's caused a little bit of trouble
just like the crossed arms to just
because I was a pickle be thank you very
much crikey it was an Australian
Australian arty look at that
I will overcoat there nice hat it looks
like the mustache that are really small
or not there's just like the beard
surrounding his framing his beautiful
face yeah definitely her fan art I love
it so much look at back the face
what did they say did they say like
known as Bigfoot or Bigfoot's actually
just her yard his head so good I love
this whole time I love the shine on the
butt right there caramel shark wren
thank you for that that's awesome yeah I
really awesome just another classic
dirty Johnny dirty Johnny Chan I guess
we can show dirty Johnny's now but since
we've we've blown the lid off this game
yeah I've gotten actually a lot of dirty
Johnnie's and I always ignore him
because we usually don't do spoiler
warning before these oh man that Fox had
no maybe that's what you get yeah I
agree I think that is a good call next
time I'll do a little preparation
beforehand sounds good so we can get
some definitely oh man yeah dude we got
some cinematic silhouettes of pig man
here that is dope he's got a Fang or
something something so sick some evil
wizard and oh yeah evil wizard it also
gets a little creepy that Holy Mary
there's something under our floorboards
can you go have a look this is big man
big man he's got some creepy looking
ones I like no coat on this it looks
creepier he's got a little bit of a
hunch you know mm-hmm she's creepy and
this is the evolution of dirty already
the timeline oh yeah this is really good
look at all look at the journey the
journey of dirty Artie many faces of
dirty Artie what's your favorite one
your favorite rd iteration I think
Pigman is my fake man is up there the
classic raccoon hat really solid again
oh no I love that hat so much very cool
it is yeah speaking of the classic
raccoon hat that crusted dirt this one
particularly smells hashtag shows you're
already I didn't see it either
again the raccoon hat the dynamite the
axe very awesome that is awesome yeah I
love that beard oh it's a finer
gentleman Artie
hmm wouldn't trust them still but nope
this way we should I say that's from
Marcus gaming yeah Marcus gaming
something this one's a video that was
pretty funny where he's fishing dynamite
and like oh he says maybe you guys
should take dirty already fishing
there's my baby you should throw a
little further this blew up the boat and
falls off pretty funny
this one is twisted from port twisted
family nice little set dress ting there
yeah I'd say it's twisted yeah I'd say
so so I like how the horse is just
photobombing or maybe it's taking the
photo right there - yeah put your put
your hand right there not quite sure
what the goal is of this one just
passing this guy I also like the guy
being thrown off is like kind of like
aware of the photo being taken for the
camera I don't know about you but like
playing Red Dead now
Arthur Morgan I we've just totally
ruined him yeah we've just I just can't
take anything he says seriously yeah
this is real clever creations here
Minecraft featuring arty and beans
[Laughter]
Oh
[Laughter]
luxury Holi you could set that much on
fire and Scotty G pyromania dang that's
pretty cool that's cool
another amazing collage here all these
photos are just I like 200 sup of just
him drinking yeah take a photo with a
charred horse just keeps getting better
carry a guy without limbs yeah the upper
left what is so
oh my god a lot of drinking in this one
very honest that one on guard very
awesome
not in-game but feels like something you
would do are those beans in there this
way I feel almost human
from the art wizard this one took me a
long time to figure out what was cool
not his from real Arthur m-maybe it was
like the portrait mode but I went first
out I had to start tilting my head see
if I was looking at her so if you
haven't seen it by now in the door where
we have our Rd this is a kill cam so it
looks like it cut behind the seat and
then in the foreground we have a
tomahawk in this guy's face dead it
looks like from here it almost looks
like a lesson from The Witcher 3 you
know for sure
tall things with the horns and yeah for
sure and that's just another classic
already with a pile of bodies forgive me
with all these these dead guys and a
horse behind me I'm super proud of this
take a photo me also I'm super impressed
at how much like if you look at all
those body is none of them like are
clipping yeah each other like everything
is everything's perfect where they
should be
what's so good I love it look how it
just blinks every yeah it's so demented
I love the detail on the pants oh that's
really good that's so awesome
that's last one wazzle doop thank you
guys so much for your arty submissions
do send more and we'll include him thank
you all so much we'll see you next week
bye bye
you